avec depuis le royaume-uni avec batman
kahniens expert en maladies infectieuses
à l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
baratta bancaire merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on le rappelle
un pays le plus maxine et d'europe
pourquoi le royaume uni est il autant
touchés par l'autre variant un bien
qu'est ce que ça dit de gouttes muse et
bonne nouvelle c'est que le programme
d'immunisation au royaume uni est
couronnée de succès en majorité cela ne
signifie cependant pas que la totalité
de la population est vaccinée variant
par exemple qui vient d'inde et plus
contaminant et donc ils trouvent des
poches de personnes non immunisées
qu'ils contaminent l'eau dans la
majorité des cas se trouvent et
attendait un droit angleterre et
ailleurs où une large partie de la
population vient d'inde du pakistan du
bangladesh où d'autres régions
similaires
c'est là que le vaccin a été repéré
c'est là qu'on trouve un nombre
grandissant de cas au 21 mai 55 7 % de
la population est muni avait reçu une
première dose du vaccin
ça veut dire ce que vous êtes en train
de nous expliquer que les nouveaux
contaminés sont à chercher plutôt dans
la partie non vaccinés en tout cas de la
deuxième dose est pas dedans l'ine
fakher l'inefficacité probable du vaccin
novak c'est le vaccin est très efficace
contre le variant soutenu c'est la bonne
nouvelle ça laisse des causes et des
variants en venant de plus la seule
chose qui est certaine concernant ce
variant venus d'inde c'est qu'il est
plus comptage
lorsqu'on a reçu une seule dose du
vaccin
on a toujours vu les raves et on risque
d'être contaminé par ce que le niveau
maximal de protection intervient après
deux doses de vaccin
lescoules de personnes notamment parmi
nos plus jeunes doivent encore être
vaccinés et s'ils se trouvent dans les
régions où le virus circule à l'heure il
est très facile pour eux d'être infectés
il ya aussi une distinction entre les
vaccins lorsque vous au royaume uni vous
avez deux vaccins de pfizer et beaucoup
d'astrazeneca
il semblerait que ce dernier soit un peu
moins efficace contre le variant indien
c'est exact lors des world
on paye pas et tu le savais pas créé on
peut dire que l'efficacité de father et
quelques pourcents points de pourcentage
de plus que l'efficacité de astrazeneca
mais les deux vaccins fonctionne très
bien les deux vaccins protègent et les
deux vaccins remplissent leurs objectifs
c'est à dire qu'ils produisent une
mémoire immunitaire et empêche les
formes graves de la maladie
si je n'étais pas vacciner alors je
prendrai le premier vaccin disponible
qu'il s'agisse d'astrazeneca ou de
pfizer ils sont tous les deux fixé il ya
aussi la question de la deuxième dose on
rappelle que elle a été rallongée au
royaume uni au tout départ de la
campagne de vaccination pour vacciner
plus est ce que on se rend compte que
c'est une erreur de ce point de vue là
parce que finalement le variant indien
va plus vite que le temps de se vacciner
nos aïeuls kingson want to protect
souhaitons protéger la population et la
première dose protège empêche que
développeur des formes les plus graves
que la manne
10 et le décès cette stratégie
consistant à distribuer d'abord les
premières doses puis à retarder la
seconde était une bonne décision au
niveau scientifique
d'ailleurs maintenant nous avons un
stock important de vaccins de pfizer de
moderna d'astrazeneca et nous avons
changé
cette stratégie nous avons modifié
l'intervalle qui est passé de 12
semaines à 8 semaines entre les deux
doses les l'intervalle de 12 semaines a
été tout à fait correcte car l'objectif
était de tuer autant de personnes que
possible aussi rapidement que possible
maintenant que nous avons astrazeneca
pfizer et modern à une peut réduire cet
intervalle le faire passer de 12
semaines à huit semaines
la dernière fois que je vous ai eu en
interview on avait commenté la décision
du gouvernement britannique de fermer un
petit peu tardivement ses frontières
avec justement l'inde à ce que c'était
ça pour le coup une erreur au yes we
might and many explique mike whan
beaucoup d'experts dont moi-même à
disions que les critères de fermeture
des frontières
les critères pour placer un pays sur la
liste rouge n'était pas elles sont
toujours pas claires ce qui est clair
c'est que le pakistan le bangladesh qui
sont les pays voisins de l'inde avait
aidé de calais nombre de cas plus bas et
avec tt est légalement sur la liste
orange alors que l'inde il ya vécu ce le
cas ainsi qu'un autre
du coup il y avait plus de cas et il y
avait un variant plus contaminant qui
n'avait pas été de tout de suite sur la
liste rouge devient plus tard c'était
une erreur et bien sûr en conséquence le
varia le variant était importée jusqu'au
royaume uni et nous voyons mal dans
différents foyers de contamination et
une augmentation des cas sur place vous
avez peut-être entendu qu'en france le
débat sur la vaccination obligatoire ce
que vous craignez au royaume uni avec ce
variant
indien ce que vous constatez même est ce
que ça pourrait être le cas ce selon
vous en france vous ne craignez os bada
cela ne fait pourtant ce qui arrive au
royaume uni arrivera en france et vice
versa et globaux à planète
nous sommes une planète mondialisée il
faut donc faire très attention et
travailler de concert il n'y a aucune
véritable il ya nous devons endiguer la
contamination au niveau mondial et mona
lisa echenne si le royaume uni et très
vacciner et que l'union européenne ait
mal vaccinés alors c'est très mauvaise
il faut avoir un taux de vaccination
élevés dans le monde entier pour
protéger le monde entier en même temps
et ensemble merci bar à tapas ocaña
expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france